[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
check me out
[Applause]
you're about to get caught in the
claptrap
couldn't hide
without giving me a chance all i wanted
to do is
[Music]
check it out
is
is
[Music]
officially
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
check it out
check it out
[Music]
y'all
yeah um
[Applause]
is it time i think it's time
i gotta i gotta show you guys something
first
you might like it i guess i'll just do
[Applause]
this
you want to do it randy i think there
was only one thing people wanted to hear
me talk about today
so i'd like to ask that my friends at
gearbox quebec
and gearbox frisco help me out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
i mean i kind of grew up with
borderlands you know like
i played borderlands you know when i was
younger they were like part of my
teenage years like i love playing it
really late into the night with my
friends
is very near and dear to my heart
because it's one of those titles that i
played
a lot with my friends and so if you
would ask me yeah like 10 years ago that
you'd be working on
borland's three i'd have been like nah
i had that childhood friend and we ended
up
playing borderlands 2 together all the
way through
and we ended up in the game industry at
the same time
now we get to work together on
borderlands so
portland will always have a special
place in my art because of that
i remember beating borderlands 2 and
like getting to the end where you see
all the the awesome star map with the
vault symbols and being like
i don't know how but i want to work on
that game when we started
working on borderlands 3 over five years
ago
there was really just one thing that
mattered more than
anything else to us and that's that
borderlands 3
needs to be a worthy successor
about three ish three and a half years
ago we made the switch to ue4
which meant everything that we had
worked on and built up
up to that point were were gone and so
it was kind of like a building a bicycle
while you're riding it you're going down
a huge slope on a mountain
on the biggest mountain you've ever slid
down and
you're having to fix that that back tire
figuring out
the the tattoo designs for the new siren
i think i had to draw mars tattoos like
20 different times
there's a fair bit of pressure to make
sure that we do it right to make sure
that we don't do wrong by our fans
if you're not taking risks if you're
playing it safe it's not gonna work
it's just gonna fall flat i view this
game a lot like they probably felt
making force awakens it was like you
have this catalog of things from the
past
that you've got to kind of fulfill and
and make sure those fans
get we have to trudge forward and i
think we're we're doing that well
i think we're trying really hard to keep
the honor to what we have done but move
ourselves into a bold new direction
the game is so fun to make the team
that we have is so fun to work with and
the fans are so
great to work for that you cannot ask
for more
it's those moments when i get emails
from people who tell me that my work
somehow inspired them i do what i do
because
games have really helped me through some
tough times
it's been a way for me to connect with
other people
i found something that resonated with me
and i
went after it relentlessly i know
there's a lot of other people out there
that have their dreams that they want to
go after
and they might be scared and so that's
why i fight to show that like you can do
this
thank you for laughing with us for being
there and waiting because we put
our heart and souls in everything
to all the fans that enjoy borderlands
to everybody out there who's made a
little piece of fan art or
cosplay or just enjoys discussing our
games
that's that's why we get up in the
morning that's that's why we work
long hours thank you so much fans y'all
are awesome
thank you all very much for allowing us
to have the privilege of building this
game for you this has been a wild ride
and i hope you guys enjoy it
ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage
chief communications officer for the
gearbox entertainment company
dan hewitt
hey everybody how's it going
oh come on let's hear it how's everybody
doing
there you go that's what we love to see
thank you all for joining us this
afternoon and welcome to gearbox's
pax east panel we are so excited to be
here that you're here
and to everyone watching online thank
you for joining us as well
we've got so much to talk to you all
about today we've got some great game
updates
we're going to make some news we might
have a few surprises
uh so let's go ahead and get started as
you saw in that video
we do everything we do for our fans our
community
as gearbox's chief communications
officer that's what i love doing most
is connecting with each of you you know
last night i was walking through my
lobby and i had a gearbox hoodie and i
got stopped
for probably about 10 minutes and i love
talking with the fans and hearing
about your thoughts on our games we know
and we read
every single letter that you all send in
all the emails all the tweets all the
facebook posts
we're so thankful for the active
community
and we never want to take that for
granted and so i
wanted to take a minute uh and start off
the show by reading a couple of those
letters if i can
i'll be brief i promise i'm going to
start
with an email that we got from michael b
michael writes dear gearbox i'm
currently a submariner in the u.s navy
i've been in the military for just about
two and a half years now
i initially joined because i was not
sure what i wanted to study in college
with much time spent under the ocean
waters i figured out what i wanted to
study
and make my career i want to study game
development
and eventually work for gearbox your
games have given me
much needed inspiration and motivation
to pick up and learn programming on my
own
and the worlds you create are amazing
they
truly draw you in and bring tons of fun
and allow time to pass by oh so quickly
especially while down in the steel tube
we call a submarine
i want to thank you for creating amazing
games that bring happiness to myself and
others thanks again guys please continue
to do what you do best
can't wait for your next game michael
that's awesome
that is exactly the type of inspiration
and motivation that
everyone in gearbox frisco and in
gearboxing gearbox in quebec city
love to see and love to hear that's what
keeps us going and why we fight
second letter dear gearbox this is from
catherine j
dear gearbox i love your games but
wanted to write with a suggestion
i bought borderlands 3 from my 10 year
old nephew
and his parents were upset with the guns
explosions and language
could you develop a borderlands without
these thanks
so i have two i have lots of thoughts
but two things
the long and the short answer is no
the long answer is no
[Music]
seriously you guys games are rated for a
reason
pay attention to them and for free psa
to the folks at the esrb
it's rated mature and we love our fans
but not let's not get carried away about
it
all right third letter uh
this is from mike s my girlfriend and i
love borderlands i was writing to see if
gearbox is planning to be at pax this
year
since your presentations are always a
big highlight for us
because we'd love we'd love to be in the
audience actually
uh mike mike's spivax vivek are you
are you here holy crap are you here
where are you there you are dude
wait come on are you here with your
girlfriend
guys come up on stage i want to talk to
you i want to see what i want to see
what's going on
go straight down here
okay while we wait for them to come to
the stage i want to
actually seeing these folks over here
reminding me the enforcers of pax east
have been
so fantastic can we give a round of
applause for everybody who's been
working here
they are doing amazing work making sure
that everything is going
so smoothly and actually you know what
if i'm going to have them on stage i
realize i just need a microphone
so let me grab this one is this on hey
yeah this is perfect
all right mike are you back there
oh they're coming up
don't worry hundreds of thousands of
people aren't watching us right now
hey mike i'm dan how are you great to
meet you
and i'm sorry i didn't catch your name
gina how are you doing come on up here
so thank you so much for coming to the
presentation you look
like a deer in headlights it's okay
it'll be fine
uh but here take a mike i wanted to talk
to you all a little bit what do you like
what do you guys love about paling
borderlands
everything it's a good answer
yeah i love i've been playing since the
first one
it's amazing i actually love borderlands
but i love how much she loves
borderlands
um because it's like her favorite thing
in the world and uh
she's my favorite thing in the world
which is why i kinda wanted to ask
something
[Applause]
gina
will you marry me
absolutely i will
you guys that's awesome congratulations
come on let's give them another round of
applause they just got engaged here
all right we've got some things for you
behind the stage but thank you so much
for coming out
oh you're
you're amazing see i told you it'd be
fine
all right have a great backseat take
care y'all
we'll see you in a little bit
guys look that was hang on let me
give this away that was real and
unscripted i'm so happy she said yes
not the least of which i didn't actually
know what was gonna what i was gonna say
if she said no
so let's just all be happy about that
all right
that is the perfect example of what we
do at gearbox we love bringing people
together
and we love making them happy and
bringing joy to the world
which is an excellent segue to just one
more thing that i want to talk about
[Music]
[Music]
that's right y'all borderlands 3 is
coming to steam on
friday march 13th we're
there you go we're so excited to welcome
the steam community
back to pandora and that's something
that we're really looking forward to
but there's one more thing that i wanted
to talk about with this
if you go to steam today you can add it
to your wish list
right now so when you leave here make
sure you go ahead and do that
another piece of news is that
we are going to be able to bring on
friday march 13th we're going to
be having pc cross play between epic
and steam so
so if you're on epic and your friends
are on steam
that's totally fine you can party up and
play together starting from day one
now i will go there's a lot more
information that goes into pc cross play
and i would go into it now but i'm
looking at the clock here and i'm the
first presenter and if i run long
i've got an afternoon of people giving
me [ __ ] and i don't want to deal with
that
uh so i'm going to tell you go to our
blog go to our website read our press
materials
and you can go ahead and get all that
information but while you're there
make sure to sign up for your shift
account that's incredibly important
as we explore future opportunities for
shift
and look at new ways of leveraging that
it's
we encourage you to have your own
account not only are you going to be
able to take advantage of incredible
things
like the echocast twitch extension
but you're going to be able to unlock
free
special things like uh
for golden keys heads skins
these are the stuff this is the stuff
that we want to give you for free
but you got to do it with your shift
account
all right so i think that's it for me i
just want to make sure that i covered
everything we've got
borderlands coming to steam on march
13th pc cross play
we answered some letters we got a couple
folks engaged i think that's good
i'm i'm done for the day i'm going to
the bar
uh so and now i'm going to go ahead
and turn it over to my good friends at
gearbox publishing
thanks so much y'all have a great pack
sees
on your feet
beautiful deadly right in our way
that's about right no
storm can stop us
so
please welcome to the stage president of
gearbox publishing
steve gibson
[Music]
hey everyone we are so
honored that the guys at counterplay
games decided to
publish the game with gearbox publishing
it is a thrill for us
to be bring more and more games to you
guys who have been so kind to pay
attention to the content being created
by gearbox software
and we wanted to share more and more
with you as we get more games
like godfather you just saw you may
notice that we see
it's playstation 5. our friends at sony
and epic games were kind enough to let
us announce the first
known playstation 5 title at the game
awards just
a few months ago and we have more to
tell you about god fall
real really soon for for you guys here
in the room what you care about
it's co-op there's loot
and it's a slasher it is a looter
slasher these guys want to
define a new genre much like we hope we
did for you with borderlands
okay now
now just at lastpacks we announced
something else
homeworld 3. take a look
hahaha
all right want me to bring rob out hey
all right well we'll start with i'm
going to bring out rob cunningham
founder and ceo of blackridge
interactive we're working together with
rob and his team to bring homeworld
through to the world
rob you wanna come join me
hey guys hey steve oh yeah good to see
you
this is a short video yeah it was great
uh
thanks for having us here thanks for
having me here my mind is still blown
about what happened on stage
five minutes ago with mike and gina i
think it was congratulations you guys
were watching from the back
i thought she knew i thought for sure
she'd know she did not know
i was watching the monitors in the back
and i was like [ __ ] is this actually
happening
and then and and she's like the same
thing and i'm like
please say yes this is totally a fail
video yeah
right now um we were gonna get drinks if
she said no we had a bet
we're gonna but that was that was legit
when they went backstage they were
sobbing and hugging so good randy was
right in there with the sobbing and the
hugging
so um so thank god that went well
um so uh yeah with the team back in
vancouver are working on homeworld three
they're super excited
for the first time in my career this is
a team that's actually ahead of schedule
oh man which is uh surreal
like that's surreal um just about a
month ago we were down in uh
texas visiting with these guys and
showing them the first playable build
which of course as
most of you know is an early milestone
in the game's development
and it's really meant to be an
unglamorous sort of rudimentary
demonstration of gameplay and
environment
um and the gearbox team were in there
and the blackbird team were in there and
randy and steve was in there and
everyone was ready
to go and the game fired up and from the
first frame with the sound and the look
it was just
dripping with with flavor and homeworld
three-ness
and uh we were all so excited and it
went really well there were no crashes
it was fantastic the ships were
exploding and blowing up
a massive cruiser comes out of the
shadow of a big derelict covered in
lights randy starts swearing
you know like soiling his trousers
yeah it went really really well so we're
super excited um
so thanks for uh the fig campaign i
think steve's going to talk a little bit
about sure
a second yeah uh thanks to all the
supporters of that campaign all the
homeworld fans and all of you guys
right here today thanks very much yeah
thank you sir
yeah thank you man okay all right
all right now imagine you've been wowed
by a trailer and i'm going to tell you a
little bit more about that and in fact
actually um so at last pax we announced
not only are we
uh putting together home of three with
rob and his team we also decided to do
this in collaboration with
the fig folks now what's special about
that is uh
it is an open communication and
development process there will be
updates happening
regularly about how things are going
like rob told you here there's a new
update coming out in march
and what you can do with fig is you can
actually sign up
and you can participate in the success
of the game
in fact uh we when we open the campaign
it's already brought in
over a million and a half dollars of
people betting into they think homeworld
three is going to work out
rob said it's going to work out so
what's also interesting though is
weirdly enough the backer has set a
record with the fig
campaign is actually the largest ever
average uh investment per backer
now this thing is still open we still
would love for more of you folks to come
on board and actually
learn more about how the game's
progressing you can actually offer
feedback to the team and they're
actually affecting the game as it
develops
as although is ahead of schedule at the
moment
it is video games but it's going really
really well and we're really thrilled
and we want you guys to actually
participate in the fake campaign and you
can affect how the
what things are prioritized with story
and campaign and multiplayer and all
those different components we're
thinking about
now one other real interesting fact
about the fake campaign is those people
who
who are in or wish to jump in we also
announced that we're going to bring
homeworld to mobile now uh last box we
said uh
it's going to be on the phone i can
confirm it is on a phone
and we have a trailer now to prove to
you take a look
hyperspace jump complete
strike group moving into position
getting banged around here
weapon set to full power
that's all i've got for you guys today
but i believe somebody with a better
voice to me is going to announce the
next person coming out
if not i will do it am i doing it what
am i doing
oh man oh my gosh
i should have looked at the prompter one
last thing a year ago
i actually was out here announcing with
paul risk of rain two
and we actually launched it that day on
pc
yes
it sounds like many of you actually play
this a heck of a lot of people played it
we're really thrilled of the reception
how that's gone
and since that moment we've announced
great sales figures and all that stuff
going forward there's more to come
we help those guys now available on
nintendo switch xbox one and playstation
4.
it's all kinds of places and we're still
bringing it to more places to come
and have a couple more updates for you
guys as we continue to support that game
for you
first uh we have the hidden realms
content update
it is going to be hitting consoles on
march 24th that's right around the
corner so those you who love the
features that you've played on the pcu
on trident console that's coming right
around the corner
and next i have an announcement for you
guys the next content update for pc is
march 31st
and that is the what are we calling
again the artifacts
update that
yes now
there's a lot more to learn about that
there will be dev vlog updates to
continue to
update you guys on what's happening
there we are so thrilled and honored to
work
at gearbox hosting with talented
developers like copu games
and it has been a privilege now we're
going to keep doing this
we're hopefully going to keep bringing
games like brisket rain and put it in
front of you guys
thank you so much for your support of
risk rain i hope to be here again with
you guys next time sharing another great
game
thanks for your time today
please welcome to the stage
director of licensing for gearbox erica
stead
so i'd like to ask you a few questions
just think about the answer quietly be
honest with yourself
do you frequently lose small items such
as keys
do you have difficulty spelling the
month february
have you ever avoided seeing your family
because you're afraid you don't fit in
is your life just missing that spark of
joy
we got you boo
do you struggle to select the perfect
gift for your mother
your significant other your cousin
bartholomew that one friend who's really
fun but
only in small doses
you have an irresistible compulsion to
have more collectibles on your shelf
than your smug neighbor jennifer
we got you boo but not you jennifer
not you if you're like me
your soul is empty and you need to
compensate yourself for that
by owning things to make up for
hey guys what's on this teleprompter
right now who wrote this
yeah i know i wrote it but i thought
that dan would
fix it when he approved it okay moving
on
so as you may have guessed we've been
really hard at work
on our borderlands merchandise program
our goal last year was to have more
products
in more places than ever before and
we do in fact got you boo but now we
just have to keep growing
more bigger better do it again next year
so as we embark on that mission we're
incredibly dependent
on two things the first is really great
partners
so it may surprise you to know that
gearbox employees don't actually
hand carve action figures in their spare
time between game development tasks
and we're not great at that so we have
to find partners who are awesome at the
things that we don't know how to do
and we've been really fortunate to find
some partners who are really great fits
who really understand our games and our
characters and share
our love of always imagining what's next
so last year we partnered with amd for
borderlands 3
but also for hardware for the studio
itself
so they got really excited and they
brought in their partner zydax to work
on the pcs that we actually used to
develop the games
and zydex got really excited and they
wanted to bring those pcs to you
so you can actually buy the exact pcs
that we are using to work on the game
and right now you can get a hundred
dollars off so go to zydax.com
gearbox for all the details and use code
gearbox
we also have a lot of partners hard at
work on let's see
t-shirts key chains hoodies incense
burners
collectibles posters
rubber duckies you know basically
everything you could want
and our partners really put in a lot of
time and attention
to you know working with us
understanding the game
getting every design just right and
honestly they often have to put up with
a little bit of fussiness from us
as we want everything to be just right
um one really good example of the time
that our licensees put in
is level 52 who you may not even know
is working with us because they've just
been quietly hard at work
on this thing and this thing is awesome
it's enormous um and for the record this
is
not a render this is an actual physical
prototype
we can prove it so obviously they're
going to be working on the paint
and then we hope to get the pre-orders
open for that coming soon
and then there's another thing that we
are so dependent on
as we try to make you know more better
different products and that is
all of you guys so it's your passion
that allows us to be able to make these
things
and you know it's you guys who bring the
passion the imagination
you point us in the right direction you
tell us how we're doing
every time i go into a meeting to try to
make a new partnership to make a new
product
i show them at least one picture of the
players that we meet
at events just like this so you are the
reason that they want to work with our
games
so thank you
so you all know you're clapping for
yourselves right
okay so on that note in honor of
all of you even jennifer our partners
have put together some really great
offers
just for the pax weekend um going to be
a lot of stuff coming at you really fast
so you might want to get out your phone
take pictures or if you're not fast
enough
check out the gearbox loot instagram
that's at gearbox loot on instagram
we're gonna put
a rundown of all these discount codes on
our story after the panel
okay so first of all our own
gearboxloot.com
has a giveaway going on this is a no
purchase necessary giveaway
just go to gearboxloot.com for all the
details
then we have some partners who are
actually here at pax
control freak is giving us five dollars
off of the claptrap
thumbsticks and they are here on the
show floor that does work
on the show floor or online volante is
giving us ten dollars off of borderlands
jackets for this weekend only
and that does work on the website or at
their booth at the show
for some online only deals we have graph
gaming giving 25 percent off of
borderlands and that is only for this
weekend
and we've got a buy one get one 50
percent off from designed by humans on
all borderlands shirts
and then okay this next one is kind of
insane
if you don't already have the art of
borderlands 3
1 you should and 2 you should get 40
off on it that is only going until march
2nd because that's an insane deal
and then next we also have a really
great one from what a workshop they're
giving us 20
off of both the mini epics and the
figures of fandom
um those codes you can use those to buy
more than one figure but the two codes
won't work on the same transaction so if
you're going to buy
many epics and figures of fandom do two
separate orders
and then the other thing that is
exciting today
we actually have some new product that's
coming out on gearboxloot.com
there is we have a t-shirt that's really
cool
that i really wanted to show you guys um
hey where's where's my blue shirt
randy has the shirt
so why does randy have the shirt
he wants to do a magic trick with it
do you guys want to see a magic trick
randy can we see a magic trick ladies
and gentlemen
please welcome to the stage founder of
gearbox software randy pitchford
i got the shirt i got the shirt
are you gonna show it yeah i'm gonna
show it this this is a canoe shirt this
is pretty awesome
it's uh it's got some new exclusive i
actually have the original art
oh it's it's i've got it in this
envelope i'm gonna show it to you
actually i don't want to show you what's
on the shirt yet i want to do something
fun
um i'm going to need some help from
somebody in the audience
um it has here's the thing though this
is going to seem like mentalism like uh
like i've read
i've been able to see the future and the
only way for you to believe this
is if whoever's chosen is chosen
completely at random do we have a
do we have that beach ball all right
can you throw it out there let this
thing bounce around and we'll start the
music
okay let this thing bounce around a
little bit
you don't know when the music's gonna
stop
send it back send it back send it back
take it back send it back oh oh somebody
grab it somebody grab it somebody grab
it who's got it
who's got it somebody's got it
of course right in the middle impossible
okay so
you uh is it a gentleman can you stand
up
what is your name mike can you walk
can you make your way over to this side
of the stage you're gonna help mike's
gonna do you guys believe mike has a
free random choice
mike mike do you know me have we ever
met before
we we have met do you guys still trust
him
you don't trust him mike i don't trust
you
mike this isn't going to work unless
they trust you
[Music]
he's doing it you guys can we give him a
chance
can we give mike a chance okay go over
there mike see the enforcer i'll get you
on stage
so here's what we're gonna do i've got
in this envelope
i have an original piece of artwork
of a character it's one of a kind and it
was created by the artist of gearbox
software
and uh you guys don't know what it is
but i'm going to give you some hints
about what's inside
uh it is it is a picture of a vault
hunter
okay it's one of the vault hunters from
one of the borderlands games you know
woodlands one word lance two borderlands
three
and it's a person it's not a robot
we love robots claptrap's not a vault
hunter seriously we'll get mike out here
those aren't vault hunters
okay so here's what we're gonna do um
we're gonna see
uh i've got this art in here we're gonna
see if mike
can actually guess what it is and if he
guesses it i'll give it to him and if
not
i'll find some other way oh hi mike can
you step up hi nice to meet you
uh you say we've met before i'm sorry i
don't recognize you once last year
okay fair enough mike uh this is your
mike mike hello mike
mike meet the mike mic all right
i'm going to make this better for you
can you you're tall okay
i'm tall now can can you can you speak
into that let's hear you
say hi mike hi guys okay mike
i have in this envelope an original
piece of concept art of one of our vault
hunters from borderlands one two or
three
you don't know which one do you you have
no idea okay
um i'm gonna ask you to guess don't
don't say it out loud i'll ask you in a
moment
but i want you to guess what i've got
because if you get it right
i'm going to give you the concept art
you're going to get to keep it
now odds are pretty low but i don't know
i you might be a pretty intuitive person
what do you think
thank you okay um and uh i want you
to help you can we get on the screen uh
the vault hunters
from borderlands one two and three you
know them right you've played the games
okay why don't you look at look at the
vault hunters and and
and see if you can guess which one it is
see don't don't say it out loud just
commit one to your mind
okay do you have one in your mind yep
okay
that's not gonna be the one sweet i want
you to forget that one
change your mind and pick a different
one don't tell me what it is
all right you got it yep that's not the
one i want you to forget that one
change your mind and pick another one
okay
okay this is the one are you sure you're
gonna lock this one in
once it's locked in we're not going to
change our minds this
is the one okay do you have a vault
hunter in your mind yes
okay let's get rid of this for the first
time
well you know what i think he should say
it first because if i pull it out
he's going to say oh that's what i was
thinking right okay
tell everybody which one you're thinking
of i was thinking of mordecai
holy [ __ ]
no way you guys can you believe this let
me show you you're not you're not going
to believe this
it's it's mordecai you guys
do you recognize him come on this is a
vault baby
you guys like the yoda can we
this is a vault baby this is mordecai
this is no look you can see it you see
in his eyes that's his eyes
oh yeah that's it you're not believing
this is mordecai i swear you guys
no it's mordecai
holy [ __ ] that's mordecai and and
uh that's a vault baby now um the vault
baby is a new piece this is a new idea
here you can have that
mike um it's a new can i let me this
shirt yeah so
um this is
this is the new vault baby shirt
and look it's mordecai as the vault baby
it's crazy in fact
do we have the this you can go to
gearboxloot.com right now
and you can buy your own vault baby
t-shirt
with mordecai's the ball baby how the
how did you know
i did not it must be it must be a
miracle hey you know what you can have
this and because you're up on stage
here um we have all the swag we talked
about this is actually over a thousand
or about a thousand dollars worth of
borderlands merchandise can i just give
this all to you because we don't want to
ship it back with us to dallas
all right here take this all right take
this
take this take this all right
take this all right check this
all right here you go all right
yeah the best stuff is still on the
ground oh we got that too here we go
here you got all this
all right here you go
yeah all right you got this right all
right oh she's got a box for you
thank you mike ladies and gentlemen mike
it's not all gonna fit in the box
and hey how about erica who runs
licensing for gearbox making sure all
that awesome rich
can happen
look at this one this is like a doormat
for children of the vault
there you go there's so much awesome
stuff so um here's the thing though um
erica can we get more of this stuff
uh sure can we get another set because i
feel bad because the way the ball thing
went you guys don't trust mike anyway
so why don't we do this why don't we
give everybody a chance
even those people watching at home um
go to the instagram uh gearbox loot and
we're gonna run a contest for
another complete set of all of this
stuff so one of you guys will get lucky
i don't know how they're gonna run the
contest but uh they'll figure it out and
we'll see if one of you guys can win it
in the meantime um you guys here
deserve something right uh you guys came
out and saw us live
so what we decided to do was to make
sure that everybody in the room got a
shift code
for the like follow and obey heads and
skin set so
everybody here you should have the code
already now there's a lot of people that
aren't here and i
i'm in the mood to give things away so
this is for
everybody uh at home here i have a shift
code because you guys know what i like
to give away most right i like to give
away golden keys
so here's the shift code for five golden
keys this is the first
five golden key giveaway we've done and
uh
take a picture uh watch the stream and
use the code and redeem five golden keys
uh yeah just a little gift start off
did that fool anybody did that magic
trick fool you guys
it's pretty weird the um the method
uh a magician from um uh germany guy
named wolfgang moser came up with that
method
and shared it with me recently and i
thought oh that's brilliant i got the
greatest application for this idea
and the vault baby a lot of people don't
you wouldn't recognize why would you
know
the vault baby's actually my son when he
was a baby
and uh we we made uh we made vault art
out of it made
borderlands art out of it so uh if you
want the ball baby t-shirt it's there on
gearboxloot.com go check it out
and uh maybe i'll see some of you with
vault baby t-shirts next year
uh at pax east and maybe i can uh maybe
i'll get my kid to come out and he could
he's an adult now so he can he can sign
the
sign them for you um i it's
i gotta tell you guys do you remember
how many of you guys were here last year
when i was here
that was so crazy like my nerves were
like it was insane we worked so hard on
borderlands 3
and for you guys to come out and to have
so much support
and so much love i i just i'm so
grateful because you know we just make
wacky video games and the fact that
some of you guys like what we do is just
incredible to us
and it has been an amazing ride it's
it's been astonishing
one of the cool things about shift and
you know you're going to log into shift
to get the shift codes and and to use
you know get golden keys and stuff and
other awards but because of that online
infrastructure
we actually see a lot of data about how
the game is being played
and i thought it would be really fun
since it's been a year since we
announced the game and it only launched
just you know in time for the holiday
season last year so it's still a very
young game
but i thought it'd be fun to share some
of the statistics of how it's gone so
far i think some of you guys might be
into this
uh did you know that borderlands 3
players
have killed almost 35 billion enemies
holy crap you guys are stone cold
murderers
[Applause]
also you know i was talking about golden
keys 62
million golden keys redeemed which is
insane because they all happened from my
twitter
right so if you want to get in on that
it's at duval magic
and uh i'm not gonna stop so 62 million
golden keys you guys
how many people wondered what the most
popular pet for flack
the beast master was anybody curious we
know
we know what the most popular pet is and
it's uh it's mr chu
it is uh it's our it's our favorite skag
uh we've opened almost 20 billion chests
and we've killed almost three billion
bad asses together it's been
so fun so far uh it doesn't stop there
though
uh we know what the most popular
elemental damage type is
uh it's not electricity it's not acid or
radiation if you're gonna kill something
you wanna kill it with fire
right and uh this one
blew my effing mind this is this is
crazy
you guys have spent 38 000
years playing borderlands 3.
oh my god 38
000 years of playtime has been logged so
far
and we're just getting started you know
there's still gosh last time i checked
there's like still over a million
unique monthly users of borderlands 2 7
years later
i can't imagine what's going to happen
with borderlands 3 which you know
blew away all our records as some of you
guys saw the other thing that's neat is
you guys have also gotten rich
in the game you guys are making way too
much money
you've earned we got to figure out new
cash sinks or something i know you hate
nerfs but we got to find some way to let
you spend your money
uh you've earned over 170 trillion
dollars
in borderlands 2. now the national debt
is 23.3 trillion dollars
so if we can just turn borderlands
currency into real cash we can
pay down the u.s economy seven times
over i think borderlands is going to
save the world you guys
that's my hypothesis uh now the most
important question of all
reese's mustache
now some of you played the game and you
had to make a very difficult decision
does mush does does reese keep his
mustache or does he shave this damn
thing
okay you've already made your decision
now here's the thing game development is
hard you guys
and so we we registered the data
and it's it's tracked in uh in our
online services system is either it's
just a bit
right and a bid is a zero or a one
basically if you want to describe it in
terms we understand
the thing is we can't figure out
is mustache zero or is mustache one
but we know that two-thirds of you
wanted one thing
and one-third of you wanted the other
and we're going to figure this out
but we actually don't i'm dead i'm
telling the truth we don't know yet
which way is and favorites 66 percent of
you said you kept it or
cut it and the other third did the
opposite of whatever that was and we
don't know what it is
but i i figured since we're all here
together i'm going to use this
opportunity because i think there's a
wisdom in crowds
you know the game with the gumballs in
the jar right so i'm going to just ask
you guys we're going to use
my round of applause and we're going to
see what sounds louder and i think that
might
be an indicator of which one's the
two-thirds so how many people think the
mustache stayed on
two-thirds
all right okay how many people shaved it
off
man that's hard that sounded about the
same to me
maybe the mustache had a slight edge
okay i'll tell you what we're gonna
figure this out
we're gonna go back to our desk to
gearbox and we're gonna
figure out which way it is and maybe
i'll tweet about it
uh but i thought that was really
interesting how to share it uh
one other thing i wanted to talk about
we did something unprecedented we did a
twitch extension
uh the echocast extension scott
velasquez and his team
and folks up at gsq and gearbox frisco
worked together to make this awesome
extension for twitch
now if you've ever watched a streamer on
twitch it's pretty cool you can watch
people that you might like or not like
play games that you might like or not
like
and spend time together online if you're
a streamer it's a really great way to
to share your experiences and to reach
out to people that you might otherwise
not meet
the borderlands echocast extension is
awesome because
it connects the twitch stream with the
game itself
right and we've actually had 14 over 14
million unique viewers
since may 1st use the echocast extension
it's just 14 million unique people using
the extension on twitch alone i mean
it's a huge ecosystem that's just an
incredible number
and we want everybody to take advantage
of this and we want to inspire other
developers to do what we did right so
let's look at what we did
uh all kinds of fun stuff that happened
as a viewer
you can throw wrenches in the the works
for for the streamer you can make
you know make them make the fights
harder basically and create problems for
the streamers to deal with
we had 273 000 viewers
kill the streamer uh by using the
interfaces in the echocast extension so
if
if you want to kill a streamer you don't
like or that you like and just want to
see him squirm
see her squirm use the echocast
extension also
viewers can participate in the loot
that's earned by the streamer so a
streamer finds an awesome red chest
get some killer legendaries you can get
a chance to get that drop you log in
with shift
and it pops into your own account so you
get you get legendaries for watching
somebody else play it's amazing
and we had actually 2.3 million pieces
of loot that were dropped four viewers
on the twitch stream uh and also lots of
rare chests
and badass events there's over 18 sorry
8.2
million participations in these uh these
events
and it's just been a lot of fun but one
of the most exciting things about this
if you are a streamer and if you know a
streamer please make sure they know this
we can see very very clearly that for
people
that are streaming with the twitch
echocast extension
they're earning an average of 62 percent
more minutes watched than streamers who
do not use
this that's more than half over right
that's an incredible boost
if you are a streamer it's a great
opportunity so check out the echocast
extension
and use it your fans will love you for
it uh thank you streamers and thank you
viewers for
enjoying this experiment with us this is
we're the first people to ever do
something like this and it's just been a
blast
uh some other stuff we had some events i
wanted to share how many people played
the mali one black site takedown
free content just made some awesome
stuff
and just gave it to everybody with
borderlands 3 totally free uh
super hard we had 28.4 million takedown
attempts
14 success rate holy crap
those of you that got through it you are
the few the happy few you are the elite
uh if you haven't got three yeah keep at
it man it's tough
i actually haven't beaten it myself with
my legit non-cheating dev account
and uh it's hard man so i'm one of the
i'm one of the you know one in six of
you actually got this thing down which
is uh pretty gnarly
uh we're gonna do more takedowns now
there's a lot of great content in
borderlands and a lot of it is extremely
accessible but we know there's some
power users with
extremely uh killer builds and killer
gear
and they want to be put to the test and
that's part of what these uh what these
takedowns are for
you know after we launched the takedown
which initially started as a four-player
co-op rate only
we then unlocked it so that single
players can take it on and it would
scale to your team size and what was
interesting
you know we always second guess our
balance and our math because we just
want to get it right but it's impossible
because there's a million dollars to
turn
the takedown uh success rate stayed
exactly the same when it was a
four-player co-op or when we did the
takedown scaling
so for some reason we nailed we nailed
that uh balance
exactly the same take out rain even
though we scaled the difficulty
um but that's not always the case and so
thank you guys for bearing with us as we
tune things
we're seeing all the data we are doing
everything we can to make the game
better for you and sometimes
some of the tweaks we make i know some
of you guys might think that they're not
for the best
but we will adjust our mission is to
entertain and our mission is for you
guys to have as much fun as possible
and we're just going to keep working on
the game and keep supporting the game
uh we had some other events a lot more
accessible some of you guys had a lot of
fun with the bloody harvest
i wanted to share it was great in the
bloody harvest
a billion and a half ghosts were killed
during the the window when that was
live that's amazing and uh the boss at
the end
captain hot we had 1.75 million
takedowns of camp captain haunt so
a lot of you guys got some great loot
from that uh a lot of fun there
um that's all the past that's data about
the past but i know
one of the things you guys are here for
is to learn more about the future and uh
i'm excited thank you i'm excited to
talk about the future of borderlands
uh there's a lot to talk about one thing
i don't know if you guys saw this uh but
we're making a movie
did you guys see that we are making a
borderlands movie and
uh it was my great thrill to uh
with our partners at lionsgate to
announce you know this movie
uh we actually first talked about it way
back when we first did the arrangement
with lionsgate
uh and lionsgate is a great studio you
know they did the hunger games they did
um twilight they know how to do big
movies and they're really behind this
picture which is really exciting
uh and then we also got involved a
production company arad productions i
don't know if
you guys probably don't know who our
production is but avi ahrad was the
founder and ceo of
marvel studios have you guys ever heard
of marvel studios
so you know they figured it out right
they made a movie called spider-man
and then x-men and then iron man and
then the avengers
they figured out how to make some of the
most incredible entertainment that the
world has ever seen
and have it come from a comic book and
so avi and ari
uh when they called me and said hey we
we think we can do this we
we think we we're the guys for video
games and we want to be the ones to
finally make a video game movie that
doesn't suck
and uh and we think borderlands
is that game now guess what i think
we're in that world right
did anybody see the sonic movie it was
cool right it's a lot of fun
they're we're getting there the studios
are behind this now
and so our odds leading the way and they
started to assemble
a great team so one of the first things
we thought we should do is write a
script
and develop the story we got some great
people to help us develop the story
and uh the the most recent writer who
turned in
i'm going to tell you it's a brilliant
script there's a guy named craig mason
do you know who craig mason is he won an
emmy
uh for chernobyl
right which is serious stuff he created
it and he wrote it
he also wrote some of the hangover
movies
so this guy's got some range he can make
us feel stuff and make us laugh
and pee ourselves right so craig is
amazing and his script is incredible
and uh so then we had the most difficult
problem of
all this a movie is not a movie unless
there's someone leading the charge
and if there's a director that gets the
vision that
understands how to tell a story and
understands how to motivate
and inspire and i was a great thrill to
announce that after a lot of work
uh and a lot of collaboration eli roth
joined the team did you guys see this
holy [ __ ] you guys eli roth is directing
the borderlands movie holy [ __ ] now
here's what's cool
you guys don't know this eli is actually
from boston did you know that
eli's local and um i i thought since
we'd literally just announced this and
we're here in his hometown
what if uh what if eli could come and
tell us what he thinks about the
experience of directing the movie
do you guys want to meet eli ladies and
gentlemen where is he
eli roth
what's up thanks randy
what's up bob hunters how are we doing
all right i'm
so holy [ __ ] right i'm so excited to be
here
uh i'm streaming to everyone around the
world and as randy said
uh this is my hometown i grew up in
newton so a special
shout out to all my boston people i'm
going to say something in bostonian
dude it's [ __ ] wicked awesome be here
i got [ __ ] wicked hammer last night i
went to donkeys this morning i had like
four crawlers i'm like wicked wired
right now
so thank you that was only my awesome
people um
but what a great thing i mean it is a a
mad
insane family and it's like it's great
when you have you know randy and
craig who wrote chernobyl and you can
put a little spice uh hostile in there
i'm so excited to uh to do something and
there's
i think the movie's gonna be great it's
incredible we're just getting started so
there's nothing to share yet
except i've noticed that there are a few
cosplayers in the audience
most are most of our cosplayers over
here can you guys stand up
look at these cosplayers holy [ __ ]
i mean i get to write a character and
see them but for
randy he writes it it's digital and then
you see them but seeing you guys in real
life
is really firing up my brain for the
movie and something that i want to do
is i don't know how we're going to pull
this off because we haven't picked where
we're going to shoot it but i want to
find the craziest cosplayers
and most psycho psychos around the world
and i want to kill them in the movie
i don't want to just put them in the
movie like oh there's a cosplayer i want
something
horrible crushing you or some awful
death because
for the super fans of the game to not
only live in it and be in it but when we
get to actually build the world
we want to find people around the world
and bring them in and just maim them
just do horrible things to them
so you know it's going to be a long road
before we get there but it's what a
there's no better way to kick it off and
just thank you everyone for welcoming me
i really appreciate it
dude that's so much fun all right
thank you thank you eli eli rob
everybody
holy [ __ ] can i see you guys for a
second
i'm gonna man oh my god you guys are so
awesome
can we get a camera on our cosplayers
holy [ __ ]
are you guys i hope some of you guys can
stick around later you know we're going
to be at the site we're going to sign
autographs down in the
uh i'll tell you where when when the
slide comes up but
i want to meet some of you guys like you
guys it's just amazing to me when we
make all this stuff virtually right
and you guys manifest it in the real
world it just blows my mind like we're
all digital and you're real
and it's beautiful i can't wait to meet
some of you guys thank you so much for
being here enjoying the moment
what else uh
i got a road map for you you want to
hear about what's going on in the game i
got a road map
we're going to talk about some things uh
i know a lot of things
one thing that you guys are all very
excited about is the next campaign dlc
right dlc2
uh it's coming it's coming in march it's
a big premium campaign add-on
we're going to go into it in a minute
i'm going to show you all kinds of cool
stuff about it
there might be a trailer you're going to
know all about the dlc
uh and of course if you own the season
pass it's already included
uh you've already you already own it and
you'll get it uh if you don't own the
season pass you're welcome to get in on
that
or you can uh or you can get it all
apart but it's
it's super awesome i'm super pumped
we'll come back to that uh we got a
bunch of other stuff free stuff that
everybody will get whether you have the
season pass or not
this is stuff for everybody one thing
coming up is a new
upgrade to the mayhem system we're
calling it mayhem 2.0
and this is going to unfold in april
it's awesome for players that have
completed the main campaign and they
want to keep
experiencing fun stuff to do in the
borderlands the new
uh mayhem mode is going to have a lot of
things that extend and evolve
the system that we originated when we
launched the game
there's 25 new modifiers more than 25 uh
actually
and there's all kinds of fun stuff like
um i mean i'm not going to go into all
25 right now but
like there's simple stuff like a big
head mode which is exactly what you
think it is
and then there's other like crazy stuff
like floor is lava
where when you when you stay in one
place like like you have to keep moving
or you're just gonna
you know melt it's it's pretty cool um
and there's
uh there's some awesome stuff you're
going to discover there's 10
levels of mayhem for you guys to work
through with uh
gear and loot up on the way that as you
earn that gear it helps you with the
next level
and it's super fun and i really can't
wait until we can watch it and it's
coming very soon it'll be here before
you know it in april
we also have a new event coming up i
call it the cartels event
it's the revenge of the cartels this
also launches in april this is going to
be a free
in-game event and you'll take out cartel
operatives and there's all kinds of fun
rewards
uh new loot uh new heads and skins cool
stuff
to to earn and do with that free event
that'll launch
in april uh we also have another
takedown coming
and this one is going to be gnarly it is
a guardian takedown
it's a iridium theme we're going to be
uh facing off against some badass
guardians and some guardian champions
and this is a free content update like
the others that i mentioned before
and it's got all kinds of fun challenges
and tons of great new
loot and new free upgrades now by the
way it's what is it
it's almost march we launched the game
in um
september i guess it's been about six
months
all this stuff all the heads and skins
we're putting for free
in these takedowns and these events
there hasn't been a single micro
transaction
for borderlands 3 as promised
now i i don't know how long we'll be
able to keep it up this stuff is
expensive to make but
we we uh right now the game's doing
great and you guys it's because of you
guys
and we're going to keep it up as long as
we can
you know we supported we supported
borderlands 2 we launched a dlc for
borderlands 2
six years after the game launched so
we'll see how long we can keep this
going but
it's all up to you guys we want to do it
we love it we're having a blast
and as long as you guys love the stuff
and and people keep
joining the community if you get your
friends to play it helps and it supports
the effort of the developers so
thank you guys so much uh the season
pass
there's more than just dlc right the
season pass has four
dlcs we already got the uh moxie's heist
to the handsome jackpot
did anybody play that it was awesome
right
now that was a great that's what
campaign dlc should be
it was massive like i i put our dlc up
against
any dlc in the industry and the moxie's
heist
definitely is in the upper echelon of
anything we've ever done
in borderlands in any previous game and
we're keeping that trend up with all of
our campaign dlcs this is going to be
the most
value-packed season pass i think in the
history of games
uh and we we can see ahead now working
backwards from the end
we're just beginning dlc four so i can't
i don't there's
there's still so much uncertain about it
but i wanted to give you a little list
of hints
um about what the nature of dlc4 is
uh there's a character that i love that
a lot of us love that was not in
borderlands 3
and uh we think that that character
deserves
a showcase and uh and not just that
character there's gonna be lots of
characters
fan favorites and uh new and old and uh
and basically uh the hint that i'll give
you is we're gonna see and this isn't
locked in stone yet so don't crucify me
later if we change things
because we're just getting started on
this but uh we're gonna see if we can
experience what it's like to be inside
the head of
the wildest psycho we know i'll just
leave it at that
um dlc three can we get the deal the
yeah let's get that slide back up
uh dlc3 uh i actually we're we're
actually neck deep in it right now
and uh we we've got we know what it is
we got our concepts built we're actively
working on it
and uh i i got our partners to agree
that we should share
uh a concept a piece of concept art so
you understand what the theme is and
where we're going
it's just concept art it's not game
we're talking about dlc3 now
right so we're still down the road a
little bit but i wanted to tease that as
well
so can we bring up that concept art
check this out
so this feels kind of westerny right
like this is like we're talking about
we're talking about like i mean what's
the best way i can this is like a
fistful of redemption in the borderlands
this is
this is this is going to be awesome um
again i don't want to give too many
details
you can expect that when the time comes
we'll go all in with the trailers
we'll give all the details long before
it comes out so you'll know it's coming
uh and we'll get there soon enough uh
but today
today we're here to talk about dlc 2. we
know what it is
and we're ready to unleash it and i want
to share with you
i'm going to we're going to go into it i
thought we'd start with the title
what is the title of dlc2
guns love and tentacles the marriage of
wainwright and hammerlock
uh where do you see this key art this is
freaking cool can we show the key art
look at this we are putting the love
back in lovecraft
[Applause]
sir hammerlock and wainwright jacobs are
getting married and there's a cthulhu
nightmare
unleashed upon their wedding that
they're gonna have to deal with and
guess what a lot of our friends are
gonna be there to help
uh some friends we're familiar with and
some new friends
and we look we've got a trailer
we'll get to that but we thought it'd be
really fun since we're all here together
and we're live
what if we got some of our voice actors
that are in
the dlc to come out and we did a live
performance
of uh do live script read for you guys
uh and it's it's this is now this script
we wrote this this is exclusive to
pax east this is happening right here um
our uh
our team with uh i think sam worked on
this one the most
sam are you back there where are you
sam's here hey sam sam's actually an
enforcer
and and he's uh on our writing team with
uh
uh varnell and danny and and uh
all other guys and and uh we wrote this
script
to set up this dlc and we got our voice
actor so
i think i should introduce our voice
actors now these the next two
actors i'm going to introduce and the
characters they play they are in dlc too
now of course you know one of them uh
please welcome
david wald as wainwright jacobs
david
can you can you grab a seat here uh and
uh
another actor who plays a character that
i really love
that i'm grateful is in this dlc please
welcome
sharamile as gage
now there's some other characters that
are in this skit uh they'll
show up when they do as cameos uh and
one of those characters is actually
uh me as crazy earl so
i'm gonna take my seat here and uh you
guys ready we're gonna do uh we're gonna
do a live script read
um you ready for this
um i just realized i haven't really
thought about
like like how do we kick this off like
yeah
um we need like a director or somebody
to come out and like yell action
[Applause]
about that all right is everyone ready
uh are we ready
you you want to do it let's do it ready
and
action
now this wedding has got to be perfect
on my name ain't wayne roddell frisco
jacobs or at least it won't be for long
i quite fancy adding hammerlock to that
list of names
i thought proposing would be the hard
part but we're choosing the wedding
planner today
and i'm so nervous i'm about to jump out
of my damn
boots alistair ought to be here by now
well speaker the devil he's calling me
now on the echo
winnie my love i'm afraid i won't be
home in time to interview those wedding
planners
this blasted hunt is taking longer than
expected but
if i am successful tonight you and i
shall
dine on the varkid queen him of oris
and if not i'll pick up some fried
chicken on the way home
no there she is now good luck i just
know you'll find us the perfect wedding
planner
well blast me to balthazar it's all up
to me
i guess i'll get started looking at the
applicants
so let me see first we got a resident of
pandora
crazy earl
what you want
what do i want aren't you here to
interview for the wedding planning
position
i don't believe in the institution of
marriage or the notion of two people
lacking each other without
a door between them
well maybe it's not for you but i'm
marrying the man of my dreams
alistair hammerlock i won't settle for
anything
less than the best and money is no
object
money is definitely an object and i
want it i'll take that job hold on to
your spurs there mr
uh crazy wait
crazy is your last name well what's earl
then
that's my job title i'm saving up to be
a duke
let's move on what are your
qualifications
well i love money yeah i believe i've
heard enough
you can't talk to me like that i'm an
earl
i'll have you put in the stocks chump
you get out of here and quit wasting my
time
joke's on you i'm gonna eat your car
let's move on to the second applicant i
just hope this one's a bit more
refined than the last one
well welcome what envy devil
bring me the bucket and i'll show you
the bucket
bucket what are you talking about
they told me to bring a pants
you look pale enough for me all right
now wait just a damn minute young maniac
are you here for the job or do i need to
show you the business end of a jacob's
shotgun
i'll plan weddings oh
all right then now i should tell you my
fiancee and i are as different as chalk
and cheese
he lives to kill rare and dangerous
beasts
as for myself a good mystery novel and a
whiskey by a roaring fire is all i need
now what kind of wedding do you think
would fit both
our diverse sensibilities
come see my top
i'm beginning to think you may not be
playing with a full deck
or even a pair of twos say
i think i saw some spoiled meat outside
would that be of more interest to you
will you morrow me i'll make hammocks
out of your eyelids
well that boy is
battier than a vampire slumber party oh
alistair
i'm trying one damn thing you asked me
to do and i'm
failing at that the only applicant left
has
red flags all over criminal history
anarchic tendencies brings a murderous
robot with her
everywhere well i suppose i might as
well interview her
hiya i'm gage well you look normal
enough guilty you must be wainwright
hammerlock told me all about you we go
way
way back oh well all right oh hey hey
babe this is the place
well i knew it i damn well knew there'd
be something wrong would you get back
you
robotic killing machine oh no no no um
my bad that's
just trap my robo best bud and literal
partner in crime i made it myself he
watches my back and
super murders my enemies oh and he also
makes
a terrific margarita oh
well i do enjoy the occasional margarita
okay so i know that planning a wedding
can be super stressful but
i did a little work in advance i even
found a venue that i think you are going
to
love you want to see
do you guys want to see
all right let's check it out
[Music]
oh yes the festivities are quite well in
full swing
what more could the heart desire
well now that just looks delightful
just perfect in fact gage you've got
yourself the job
yes oh yeah freaking crushed it
oh yeah i'm so sorry uh that
still kind of happens sometimes uh
okay uh so let's talk guest list wayne
wright
i'm gonna bet that there are a lot of
people
that just don't want to miss the wedding
so what's the date
oh march 26th
march 26th i am on it
see you all there
awesome you guys you did it
let's hear it for our talent david wall
jeremy lay
we got sean ahern from gearbox as our
psycho
and you guys know uh we have an
award-winning actor is death trap
it's eli roth thank you
i told you i love cosplay my first
cosplay thank you
that's the cup that's he loves cosplay
you guys
all right we did it hey thank you guys
thanks so much um you guys looking
forward to dlc too
awesome hey i am so psyched that you
guys came out and spent time with us
here today uh
it's just i can't believe it i mean look
at this room look how much energy is
here
uh i want to meet as many of you guys
that want to meet me and us a bunch of
us
are going to hang out in the autograph
session q room we'll be there at 4 30
which is
in about what 45 minutes 40 minutes from
now so we're gonna haul ass down there
if you want to go meet us
uh we'll say hi and uh guys thank you so
much for coming out i hope you had a
great time
spending time with us here at the
gearbox main theater show have a great
pax i'll see you around the show good
night you guys
[Applause]
cheers
i'm not done
[Music]
in a world of legendary heroes
one man will rise
to take all
of the credit this game has something
that
no one else will me
[Music]
this is where the magic happens hey can
i get a coffee
i'm coming everybody has that game that
they fell in love with because they make
an impact
those games were somebody's legacy well
this
is my legacy our legacy i would like to
see whatever it's not my legacy
i have a ba in women's studies what
exactly is women's studies it follows
the experiences of women
and the contributions they've made to
inquiry withdrawn
quick thing i'm worried about the time
yeah david i'm moving as fast as i can
it's not my fault that these watermelons
don't explode like real heads
i can get you real heads not human
that's commitment i built your vision
it's like you're this brilliant painter
and i'm your favorite brush
i'm just some tool to create your
masterpiece i like that metaphor but
it's not quite right is it are you
seriously about to noodle on my metaphor
right now
i know that i can be difficult papa you
can't give up i like the beatles
together we make masterpieces i could
write the lyrics and the music and
everything but it would sound completely
different without the drums
wait i'm ringo well yeah of course
you're ringo i mean look somebody's
gotta keep the beat
oh my god
at least you brought me breakfast oh
this is mine it's
prescription a prescription bagel
legally you're actually not allowed to
ask me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you